So your web browser does a great job of
concealing a lot of the complexities of
HTTP, such that the user can focus
on the web surfing experience.
But as developers, we need to be able to
dig deep to see what is going on with
requests and responses.
Luckily there are several tools out
there that we can use to generate
HTTP requests and view responses.
In this video,
I will point out two of my favorites.
If you're a big fan of command
line applications, Curl is one of
the most popular command line tools for
sending and receiving HTTP messages,
even though it can also transmit
on several other protocols.
If you prefer a graphical
user interface, Postman is
an easy-to-navigate Chrome extension you
can use to build and view HTTP messages.
Documentation for using these tools
can be found in the instructor notes.
I recommend choosing one of these
tools and getting familiar with it for
future exercises.